لقد جئت إليكم في نهاية العرض
اليوم
لأشيد دونالد ترامب بعدم دفنه
الرئيس المنتهية ولايته ترامب.
لقد دفع
إجماع السياسة الخارجية لإعطاء
أولوية أكبر لإعادة أفراد الخدمة إلى
الوطن حتى لو
كانت متابعته تريد بالأحرى أن
تكون هذه إنجازات مشروعة ،
فهناك طرق أخرى قد يؤدي بها الرئيس المنتهية ولايته
عن غير قصد
خدمة العلاقة بين  لا ينبغي أن تكون وسائل الإعلام الإخبارية
والحكومة الأمريكية في
أي مكان قريبًا من العداء
كما كانت في عهد الرئيس ترامب ،
لكن يجب أن يكون الأمر عدائيًا ،
فربما يكون ترامب محقًا في عدم
حضور العشاء
حيث يشعر السياسيون والصحفيون بالراحة
لبعضهم البعض ، وربما كشف
شيئًا غير لائق  لا ينبغي أن
يعود إلى طبيعته ، فقد كشف الرئيس أيضًا
عن المشكلة التي
يعاني منها الكثير من مشاكلنا  يبدو أن المعايير والمعايير
في الولايات المتحدة
تستند إلى نظام الشرف ،
على سبيل المثال ، لا يوجد قانون صريح
ضد رئيس أمريكي يحاول ابتزاز
دولة أجنبية
لتوفير الأوساخ
لخصم
سياسي محلي ، تعمل الحكومة التي تؤيدها نظام الشرف
فقط  إذا كان كل شخص معنيًا
قد كرم ، فهذا يبدو شيئًا
يجب على المشرعين إعادة فحصه ، ثم دعونا أخيرًا
نلقي نظرة على أحداث الأسبوع الماضي
حيث رفع الرئيس دعوى قضائية مجنونة ، وهي
القضية الكبيرة التي أطلق عليها من
المدعي العام لتكساس ،
لقد كانت مهرجًا  موجز قانوني مبني على
نظريات المؤامرة
والأكاذيب الصريحة و 18
18 من المدعين العامين للولاية بعضنا
أعضاء في مجلس
الشيوخ وأغلبية أعضاء التجمع الجمهوري في مجلس النواب ، وقد
أيدنا
الرئيس ترامب ذلك من خلال
فضح هؤلاء المسؤولين المنتخبين ،
فهم بالتأكيد
أشخاص وقعوا على
الرغبة اليائسة في تقويض إرادة
الشعب الأمريكي
لحرمان الناخبين في ولاية
بنسلفانيا بجورجيا وميكروفون  higan
على أساس الأكاذيب ونظريات المؤامرة التي
تضع انتزاعًا غير أخلاقي وفاسد للسلطة
فوق الديمقراطية ، الرئيس ترامب ، قدم لنا
معروفًا من
خلال الكشف لنا أن هؤلاء
الأفراد هم من هم وهذا أمر
مهم ونحن نمضي قدمًا لأن
أعمال هذه الأمة
تواصل الوباء
هجرة السياسة الخارجية الاقتصادية والآن نحن
نعرف
بوضوح مدى اهتمام هؤلاء الأفراد
بالحقائق أو الحقيقة إلى أي مدى
يهتمون بالديمقراطية
أو المبادئ التي تجعل هذا البلد
عظيماً
وهو ما يعني عدم الاهتمام على الإطلاق